good afternoon everyone boru I'm Maria
shell and as a graduate of the school of
engineering class of 86 and founding
president of the columbia alumni club of
france i am very proud to be here today
the leadership mentoring networking
opportunities as well as the friendships
forged within the alumni clubs are among
was amongst my dearest experiences of
the colombian so let me say to all
alumni here today get involved it's
really worth it I must admit I was not
only honored when I was asked to
introduce this panel I was a bit
mystified as well why me I wondered but
then I realized globalization is also
about getting involved and for some of
us actually about giving back because I
am actually a product of globalization
myself my parents left China or Spain in
search of an education that they would
have not been able to obtain otherwise
and he turned they made it possible for
me to study in the US and today from
London my my nonprofit endeavours
actually shifting to the developing
world as well so I'm trying to keep that
energy of globalization in motion my
sari is in no way unique indeed all of
us in the international columbia alumni
community are very well positioned to
lead the way for a better world but
globalization can also be about
exploitation and not only expanded
opportunities so how can we make sure
that the results match our intentions
and how do we have to change our
thinking to incorporate this emerging
reality of the 21st century these are
just some of the issues that make this
such an important topic and we are
fortunate today to have such a
distinguished panel to explore
globalization they are not only
extremely knowledgeable they also very
passionate and committed so don't be
surprised if we witness some fireworks
among the panelists today I think so you
know them well
that's the spirit of inquiry of
discussion of debate our university was
founded on and that the CIA and the
forum seek to advance so today it's my
great pleasure to introduce our panelist
Susan Furman president of Teachers
College Columbia University and chair of
the management committee of the
consortium for policy research and
education she is a renowned expert in
issues that the nexus of globalization
and education Jeffrey Sachs director of
the Earth Institute cattle at professor
of sustainable development and prefers
of her own health policy and management
at Columbia University he is the author
of the best seller the end of poverty
and was twice named one of time
magazine's 100 most influential people
in the world and Joseph Stiglitz
university professor chair of Columbia
University's Committee on global thought
he is a Nobel laureate in economics
former chief economists and senior vice
president of the world bank and author
of many books most notably globalization
and its discontents fair trade for and
making globalization work moderating our
discussion a scholar professor author
and esteemed leader who has already been
introduced Lee Bollinger president of
community